[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias e historias de nuestro
continente esto es lo que veremos hoy el
papá francisco reconoció los errores
cometidos durante la colonización en
contra de los pueblos originarios de
américa el 'mea culpa' llegó después de
que miles de indígenas pidieran de norte
a sur del continente que se resignifica
la fecha del 12 de octubre en
reconocimiento de las atrocidades de las
que fueron víctimas con la llegada de
cristóbal colón y los afectados por los
derrames de petróleo en ecuador han
decidido convertir el desastre ambiental
en una oportunidad indígenas y
campesinos damnificados crearon un tour
tóxico para mostrar a los turistas los
estragos causados por las compañías
petroleras extranjeras
el legado del cob y 19 legacy tower una
torre en florida es el primer edificio
listo para las pandemias un complejo
médico y residencial en uno les contamos
más en segundos
y vamos de inmediato con nuestra
historia principal el 12 de octubre las
calles de las principales ciudades de
américa latina se llenaron de los
colores de los pueblos originarios los
indígenas reivindican la fecha que fue
bautizada por españa como día de la
hispanidad y rechazan los abusos de los
que fueron víctimas con la llegada de
cristóbal colón en mexico la jefa de
gobierno de la capital claudia sheinbaum
informó en coincidencia con esta fecha
que la estatua de colón ya había sido
retirada para la restauración en el
paseo de la reforma será reemplazada por
la de una joven ama hac una mujer
indígena de la región huasteca que fue
encontrada justamente el primero de
enero en ecuador la policía fue
desplegada para proteger una estatua de
isabel la católica en quito mientras que
el presidente nicolás maduro de
venezuela se sumó al llamado del
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador a
exigir que españa y la iglesia católica
pidan perdón por los hechos unas
declaraciones a las que el papá
francisco respondió con un
reconocimiento de los errores
no es un 'mea culpa' pero se acerca el
papá francisco reconoció los errores
cometidos por la iglesia católica contra
los pueblos de américa
son tantas las tentaciones de borghi son
muchas las tentaciones de querer imponer
el propio modelo de vida como si fuera
el más evolucionado y el más atractivo
cuantos errores se han realizado en la
historia de la evangelización queriendo
imponer un solo modelo cultural o leño
en borré un solo modelo cultural
de esta manera se ha privado a la
iglesia de la riqueza de muchas
expresiones locales que llevan consigo
la tradición cultural de poblaciones
enteras de gente de proyecto población
[Música]
la admisión hecha en el vaticano llegó
luego del reclamo de los pueblos
originarios el 12 de octubre desde el
norte hasta el sur del continente miles
de indígenas salieron a las calles a
pedir que se cambie el significado de
este día en el que tradicionalmente se
conmemoraba la llegada de cristóbal
colón a américa y que se utilice para
reconocer a las víctimas de las
atrocidades cometidas durante la
colonización y visibilizar las
dificultades que atraviesan en la
actualidad como peleamos con los
gobiernos haciéndoles entender haciendo
esta lucha haciendo conciencia y
recuperando esencia no olvidando
nuestros idiomas en unidad y no permitir
que ningún pueblo diga soy de bolivia
soy de chile soy mapuche soy cochala no
somos pueblos originarios con la
identidad en el tierra donde vivimos y
somos defensores de la pachamama en
países como méxico venezuela y bolivia
el nombre del día fue cambiado de día de
la raza o de la hispanidad a otro que
reconoce las identidades de los pueblos
originarios como el día de la nación
pluricultural o el día de la
descolonización
ya los presidentes de méxico andrés
manuel lópez obrador y de venezuela
nicolás maduro le habían exigido tanto
al rey de españa como el papá francisco
que pidieran perdón por el genocidio
indígena exigir al rey de españa
que rectifique su posición que
reflexione y que le pida perdón américa
por el genocidio de 300 años contra los
pueblos originarios la polémica se ha
intensificado luego de que la jefa del
gobierno de madrid isabel díaz ayuso
dijera que los españoles no iban a pedir
perdón pues trajeron la civilización
américa ignorando que las comunidades
como las aztecas mayas chichas incas y
guaraníes tenían un elevado grado de
desarrollo y cultura cuando llegaron los
españoles
y precisamente en chile en el mismo 12
de octubre el presidente sebastián
piñera anunció la militarización de
cuatro provincias del sur del país
debido a los enfrentamientos entre las
fuerzas de seguridad y los indígenas
mapuches que reclaman sus derechos sobre
los territorios que les fueron
arrebatados inicialmente durante la
colonia y posteriormente a través de
acciones militares bajo el estado de
excepción las fuerzas armadas están
ahora a cargo de garantizar la seguridad
en chile hay casi 2 millones de
indígenas mapuches que han sido víctimas
de discriminación durante siglos como
les contamos en el siguiente informe
desde hace siglos los indígenas mapuches
reclaman la propiedad sobre su
territorio igual mapu en chile este
comprende las regiones del bío bío y la
araucanía ubicadas a unos 600 kilómetros
al sur de santiago desde la llegada de
los españoles los mapuches se
resistieron en guerra aprovechando su
conocimiento de la geografía de la zona
llena de bosques y montañas logrando
mantener su autonomía de la corona pero
con la formación del estado chileno en
el siglo 19 los indígenas fueron
perdiendo sus terrenos a descendientes
de europeos y más tarde a grandes
empresarios del país
el reclamo por los territorios
ancestrales se ha intensificado en la
última década por la falta de una
legislación gubernamental y porque en su
actual constitución los mapuches no son
reconocidos explícitamente a pesar de
representar el 12 por ciento de la
población
en las últimas semanas la violencia ha
escalado con atentados a iglesias ya
viviendas así como ataques armados a
conductores que han dejado a su paso
tanto a mapuches como policías
fallecidos y heridos
según cifras oficiales en 2021 se han
registrado mil 475 hechos de violencia
rural
46% más que en el mismo periodo en 2020
además 462 personas han sido detenidas
en medio de los desórdenes lo que
corresponde al 53 por ciento de los
arrestos de los últimos cuatro años en
la zona
y seguimos en chile- porque el
presidente sebastián piñera enfrenta la
amenaza de la destitución pero tras las
revelaciones de los papeles de pandora
un grupo de diputados presentó una
acusación en su contra por la venta de
un megaproyecto minero la transacción
tuvo un valor total de 152 millones de
dólares 138 billones de ellos en las
islas vírgenes según reveló el consorcio
internacional de periodistas de
investigación que fue el consorcio que
reveló los papeles de pandora el voto se
llevará a cabo en noviembre en la cámara
de representantes y si es aprobado
pasará al senado donde se le realizará
el juicio político con miras a removerlo
del cargo
y vamos ahora a ecuador porque en la
amazonía los afectados por los derrames
de petróleo han decidido convertir el
desastre ambiental que han vivido
durante décadas en turismo y guían a los
visitantes a través de pozos de petróleo
y lugares contaminados entre 1972 y 1990
en el noreste del país la compañía
estadounidense chevron en ese entonces
llamada texaco causó daños irreversibles
a la biodiversidad y a las comunidades
locales desde entonces varias compañías
ecuatorianas continúan extrayendo
petróleo en esta región como no lo
cuentan nuestros corresponsales
el amazonas es una región salvaje con
una biodiversidad espectacular conocida
como el pulmón del mundo
pero en ecuador el amazonas también es
sinónimo de extracción petrolera y
contaminación
donald moncayo trabaja para la unión de
afectados por texaco una asociación que
une a las víctimas de las operaciones de
la compañía en esta deforestada área
quiere mostrarnos que hay debajo de la
superficie en esta piscina no es
limpiada esta piscina fue utilizada se
beneficiaron de esta piscina
económicamente y la dejaron ya está
hasta la actualidad tal cual como la
construyeron esta es una de las 880
piscinas de crudo documentadas por
donald en 2005 donald creó el tour
tóxico un paseo para turistas y
periodistas a través de las áreas
contaminadas una manera de como
concientizar de cómo prevenir que lo que
pasó aquí no pase en otros lugares en
1972 texaco comprada posteriormente por
chevron empezó a extraer crudo en las
provincias de sucumbíos y orellana desde
entonces de acuerdo con la organización
643 millones de litros de agua tóxica
han sido descargados en los ríos y en el
bosque así como 650 mil barriles de
petróleo
cuando texaco se fue del país en 1990
solo limpio parcialmente el área del
chevrón pague el daño que ocasionó acá
para nosotros limpiar como se debe de
limpiar y vivir con dignidad esto es
nueva loja la capital de sucumbíos es
aquí donde la organización de víctimas
guarda sus archivos una batalla legal
que se ha librado durante 27 años
empresa criminal en este caso chevron
oye a la justicia y en el mundo existe
una arquitectura creada construida para
proteger el crimen que comete las
transnacionales tanto la comida como los
ríos siguen contaminados por derrames de
petróleo campesinos e indígenas reportan
innumerables casos de enfermedad y
muerte prematura en 2018 la corte
suprema ordenó a chevron pagar 8 mil 400
millones de euros para limpiar un área
de 500 mil hectáreas pero la empresa
nunca pagó a la corte de apelaciones con
sede en la haya canceló el veredicto
posteriormente la amazonía se extiende a
lo largo de nueve países suramericanos
muchos de ellos siguen buscando una
manera de extraer recursos naturales sin
dejar de proteger al medio ambiente y a
las comunidades locales mientras el
cambio climático se acelera proteger a
la amazona se hace cada vez más crucial
para el futuro del planeta
y una constructora de florida empezó a
levantar lo que considera es el primer
edificio del mundo listo para una
pandemia la torre legacy de miami
costará 500 millones de dólares y tendrá
robots que matan bacterias tecnología no
táctil y sistemas de purificación de
aire
el legado del hobbit 19 legacy towers
será parte del nuevo complejo bautizado
miami world center el proyecto nació
durante la pandemia su construcción está
en curso y los constructores dicen que
la torre será cobit consciente y estará
lista para pandemias la primera en el
mundo el proyecto tiene un componente
residencial un hotel y un complejo
médico decidimos expandir algunas de sus
características de bienestar al resto
del proyecto vemos material anti
microbios vemos robots enex vemos robots
que matan bacterias que usaremos para
limpiar legacy tower tendrá 310
residencias de lujo
219 habitaciones de hotel y 10 pisos de
instalaciones médicas desde el minuto en
el que entras en los elevadores usas
tecnología sin tacto tienes sistemas de
purificación de aire tienes la
posibilidad de tener un centro médico
aquí mismo así que si algo te pasa
puedes bajar en el elevador y cruzar el
pasillo y pedir una consulta el proyecto
de propiedad consciente de la pandemia
ya ha traído clientes tanto los estudios
como los apartamentos de una y dos
habitaciones ya se vendieron la torre
estará terminada en 2024 en un acto de
convergencia entre la ficción y la
realidad el actor william shatner
célebre por su papel de capitán kirk en
la serie star trek alcanzó la frontera
final del planeta a bordo de una nave
construida por la compañía del magnate
chef pesos el héroe de star trek de 90
años se convirtió en la persona de mayor
edad en alcanzar el espacio aunque fue
solo por 10 minutos
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa soy natalia cabrera
recuerden que pueden seguirme en redes
sociales en la dirección que ven en sus
pantallas en la producción estuvo
giovanni agudelo sigan viendo más en
france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]